I am so happy this is happening this is
gonna be awesome I am brimming with
confidence that it weights gonna be a
good sport and we're all gonna play
along it was a good sport last time we
were moderately sized nice guys guys
what we were Dana Dana replay we're
happy we're happy watch the tape what do
you I added my own videos now we're
happy go Bama that's a good role yeah
it's a pretty good role right get ready
for me to crush you guys
I like how Wade's name is just slightly
too long so it Scrolls back and forth
[Laughter]
excuse me guys my dice need to be good
did you roll a better 8 than my 8 oh you
know a baby I rolled the 8 first and I
rolled this 8 first oh yeah this is the
good stuff seems to be a lot of eights
going on yeah alright guys my epic first
turn is gonzo Oh
six dollars six dollars broke me that's
okay you want to just declare bankruptcy
in full effect
boy I'm on the Reading Railroad give it
to me give it to me give it to me yes
absolutely not probably roads not a
winning strategy very well strat hey
wait no you're just saying that I know
it's a good strat I know it's a West
Rail railroad sucks yeah are you gonna
end your turn you just stare at your
railroad oh sorry
here wait eyes which one is Wade this
one that as proof of my goodwill to you
I'm gonna give you
50 bucks I would like to offer you this
$50 free of charge how do I make my
offer how do I do this I don't know I
want to make my offer oh yeah you hit
that yeah I did it how do I now how do I
send the offer oh you got to figure out
what he wants and then just say nothing
okay good add money that's what I want
okay that's back [ __ ] this make it so
hard for me to give you 50 bucks all
right I have a solution
I'm gonna give you 51 bucks and you're
gonna give me one bucks and I think
that's a good offer you didn't put your
51 on the table all right good good good
51 good all right now this this is a
this is a start of a beautiful
friendship is really a start here I'm
doing I'm doing it I'm being it yeah I
like that I really like that yeah I'd
appreciate that it's a good game good
start good game good start in fact I'm
fascinated about this I'm fascinated by
this wait I'm not gonna give you free
money though I just want you to know
that's fine that's fine I'm really
really not gonna come pay you again what
exact copy of my normal voice why would
it muffle your sykes it's so real
it's me I said that too in the same
voice I'm so real hi Bob huh let's just
turn it off well hi Wade recorded oh
wait not again oh yeah I win hi I got
nothing guys I didn't prepare for this
if I was smart about this I would
actually set these up and happily once I
get once I get my new desk and I have my
my machine set up I'm gonna tie it has
16 buttons and I'm just gonna tie them
all to sound bites a little musical bits
and you guys are gonna love it I think
it'd be funny if we agreed ahead of time
for one stream to like assuming wait get
Cisco XLR set up at some pole
it's basically ready who do I want to
trade with why would I want to trade
with what I didn't do that I wanted to
end my turn
you did them in no I don't wanna do that
I'm hitting buttons I don't want to do
just click on it I can click on them too
no I'm trying to use the keyboard ha if
we holy [ __ ] nice roll goodbye losers
rerecord a bunch of stuff and then do a
stream where we tried to communicate
using air pretty cool although we will
never wait will never ever so someday I
have no it'll be ready by the next time
we write ok ok yeah you're leaving town
so it's definitely gonna be ready here
we go oh are you leaving tomorrow yeh
$25 that's a little overpriced lady good
right pretty good good would you
possibly know anything about to consult
on you know people with kids you know
[Music]
rich just like chocolate man I do not
remember that commercial that's I made
that up that's not real twins you say
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] where are you going buddy
where are you going I know that's to get
water works not utilities you're like
railroad and utility man that's not
that's not fair I like it well Z turn of
the century mogul have fun with your gas
lamps oh you had to ruin it Wade
universe where Spiegel is totally why
because I gave Wade fifty dollars in
goodwill the game is recording me okay
I'm gonna give Wade good sport I'm gonna
give Wade fifty dollars and you see what
good will it shines on my I will take
your money I'm gonna do it bad bad karma
and good money it's like rubbing his
head you know it's just good luck right
as long as you guys are having fun I'm
having fun buddies all right pay me all
you'd like oh I'm gonna pay you
oh you're gonna take my body 200 extra
so I said if you already know you don't
even need to talk to me cuz I know and
I'm gonna I'm gonna give them I can't
believe it for pictures doing this Bob
I'll give them what did there we go I'm
gonna give them I'm gonna give them come
on six dollars with the really $51 oh
okay all right see now I'm gonna get the
best look right right
I tried to add $1.00 okay
oh you okay yeah yeah good counter okay
now I'm gonna get the best luck right
Bob wrap up that's it's my experience or
at least I hope I took away your luck
wait you don't we took all your look you
don't get lots of luck all right that's
not that's not what we agreed upon
okay that's pretty good a hundred and
fifty 3.2 $100 you slapping we're like a
calculate was doing a really elaborate
bit where he was a 1920s accountant like
garlic to crunch divided by 35% crunch
just are right by my desk for the bit
yeah what I don't doubt it
oh yeah oh yes oh the new dice is in
effect oh you got a bus where's the bus
to again you got nine buses oh I can
choose oh [ __ ] yeah my you should choose
four no choose yeah I think about luck
is on my side
mark doesn't know what for looks like
I'm just cash register I got sick nasty
roll nice
what that means
oh god yeah that weird one okay
apparently I get this alright does that
move you to the next available property
or something was it one of the brown
ones available it was the next available
one after your role would take you there
now okay which is a bizarre thing but
I'll accept your choice it's fine if you
roll a picture of a dog a small dog
comes on screen and smells your dice if
it doesn't pee on them starting now you
gotta hold out the luck comes in later
it's slow acting luck yeah you don't pay
me again slow actin tinactin kind of
look is your actin tinactin too quick
for you you don't want that relief that
fast you want to burn through the
suffering you get slow actin tinactin
why do you guys have the bonus die every
time why don't I get that we go once you
pass the first go yeah you get there you
won't you are there just right there
you're right there you'll get it that's
right dice everybody yeah that is right
yeah you you right yeah stop
look at that it's adorable
listen look I'll give you $400 wow
that's a lot yeah well a lot of money
for that a shrewd negotiator if ever
there was one Bob I didn't mean 400
apparently 400 what am I crazy nah come
on now yeah I just look at all the
properties you guys have I've got two in
a real room oh my god we're trying here
all right we turn on can we like
handicap us a little bit or something no
it's fine it's fine
I just thought you guys are enjoying
yourself I am enjoy yes it will be
having a nominal time hey I don't care
when or lose I just want to not win and
make decisions that's nice that's real
nice way yeah I wasn't paying attention
to what you were saying do this see look
you might get rid of that you even did a
front flip
yeah hells yeah I'm buying this [ __ ] Oh
getting my trunk daddy okay
wait you're gonna get we're going to
four nice hey can I waive his fees game
is there that's only seventy it spreads
a pretty lucky amount of money to have
to pay more property sure has it come
back to pay me back for much I'm saying
it's quite impressive Bob that's quite
impressive oh that income tax well no
you didn't even you got the other one I
got
it's okay I'm gonna roll the dice again
nothing's gonna go wrong I'm cruising Oh
give me some James place please oh
please
all right slap it down maybe I don't
know it's nice nice nice nice oh it's
that hey wait wait I got that thing you
need that exact thing that you need sure
thing that I want I'll trade you one for
one Illinois for what for your railroad
my good sir that doesn't seem right
wait hang on yeah I'm equally as opposed
to this as I was the last time a bad
trade was about to happen no no no this
is legit you just put whatever you want
for my sighs it's all yours buddy this
is legit I I I have to prote I have to
morally protest this all right all jail
juice the bottle is making everybody
happy here v mark I am taking five
dollars from him for the privilege of
having his full set of reds I made that
deal for the greater good right right
okay all right yeah can I you know if
you're just giving [ __ ] out I'll take
I'll take the cheapo blue you know you
don't have any real roads okay so I need
railroad I have to have railroad it has
to be railroads wait wait gave me some
tasty value on that trade okay you don't
understand the value of railroads
doesn't mean that I'm gonna change my
friend well understand the value of
railroads but I also know that red is
one of the most valuable properties to
own no
I'm aware of this fact about that's
right it's truth its truth very true but
my strategy panning out look at this I
saw I saw this coming
I just feel I use my money's worth I
trade I feel like I feel like
something's just a little [ __ ] with
what's going on here no no I just feel
like this is just bad news I feel like
I've Mark you know what I feel like
you're trying to be in the person sour
grapes now everyone's having a good your
grapes aren't sweet mark well I think
that's rudeness how you gonna be like
that
alright guys you really you really
harshing my steez here and and i feel
like i'm maybe you shouldn't STIs all
over i'm really twisting your stem here
because i want you to play along you
know good if things ain't good I'm not
gonna just sit back and let it happen to
me I do think that I do in fact think
that you would think that I think that I
do think that you will do yeah I've done
it
I sure you would like to alright fine
whatever I'll let it go again how many
[ __ ] doubles am I about to roll I
don't understand but I'll let it slide
this once but only this once hey that's
really generous I feel like I feel like
there wasn't an equal amount of luck
going to both you and me when we rubbed
Wade's head I feel like it's really fun
to rub I feel like I paid my share of
luck for the look look it's slow acting
luck we made the Madden jokes we
reference those 90s commercials just as
true hang in this it's gonna itch for a
while but it gets better you know yeah
put the cream on there and the bumps
will go away mmm you know sound
convinced come on got two purple mark
you wanna give me your purple for like
ten bucks
purple you would have my ear to play
this and he's just not being a team
player yeah I feel like we made a big
stink about wanting to play this and
weights being totally cool and somehow
mark is being just such a just really
appreciate that birthday present reason
for you guys to start ganging up on me
it's just started happening and and like
all I did was say you hey appreciate the
way I rubbed you didn't rub me I rubbed
you well you didn't appreciate the rub
that I was involved in anyway he was a
part of the rub what an interesting
position of power you have why can't I
get five no you can't pick that one what
are your options two four and six sure
sure sure
or I'll go Community Chest but it better
be good pay two hundred dollars to wade
because of laws on the bright side you
just passed go so you got your you're
with emotes that you have are so
applicable to that scene for a get out
of jail free card for that purple
wondering why he's got bad karma
everybody I feel like that was such a
good offer wait wait you get you get the
yellow every top post your bail I don't
know what you did to get in there it's
just I don't understand what's going on
now but I liked it better when we were
all piling on wait I just say that that
was a better you being honest about what
was happening earlier I just want you
see man look at those dope houses you
got yeah so you guys have a place to
stay but it's not no no I appreciate
that that's very generous what did I
just do I bought a house an act
[Laughter]
Kentucky needed another house apparently
oh those doubles though look at envira
one more time I'll go visit mark in the
penitentiary what why didn't you
okay well that movement guy is just a
mystery I don't understand
now we can follow now we can talk now we
can I'm gonna can I not trade while I'm
in jail manage properties alright here
we go
alright wait wait you know what I want
you know what I want you you are that's
not right alright you want you want this
yeah you want you want you want I got to
consult my buddy Bob he's my property
manager Bob I don't know if that's
really it's beneficial for you is it
could be you know whatever I did it Bob
made me pay more money yeah right now
you're getting $280 and I'm getting 160
so you paid more money is through such a
mark gave such a stink about that I feel
like match the 280 there maybe toss in I
don't know some money or some is or
something I feel I feel like this is
perfectly fair but you know what I'm
just saying my cash value I paid was
higher than what
yeah and this yours is higher right now
isn't that what you wanted him in this
scenario you're him and you perfect here
we go deal yeah
that's pretty good deal no no hang on no
you don't need to we're just gonna just
hold on it's fine
warranted make sure I was participating
okay there we go
closer to the truth at some point okay
well alright sure I'm not happy about it
oh shut up mark you still got a good
deal no I'm not happy about it just
because of all the shot all the other
emotional baggage ending with it that's
what I'm unhappy about I'm being a fine
sport because I'm playing the sport
correctly there's no correct or
incorrect way everyone can play however
they want to I tell them this game work
it's whatever
well have fun in jail I guess I guess I
will you know I guess I will
all right good the good guys wait you're
in prison you're about to get something
very special no no you're not
no I can't afford this yeah oh yeah I
can't do it I can't do it have fun with
that yeah have fun with that yeah nerd
why don't you take it easy with those
houses there friend Oh listening as your
confidant that scares me for many
reasons I'll stop there I want to scare
you too much oh yeah I meant to put
houses on mine wait no Bob before you go
wait before you go this way I have to
put ok this is fine oh no it's not fine
no that's not so good I meant to put
houses on okay no you do that during my
turn I'm just saying I just saying I
meant to no I can't so if I if I land
the honor system yeah the honor system
okay okay yeah I will do this for you I
will do this
oh boy with the Devils looks like I'm
joining market no I'm not because that's
well so what I should owe you is 120 no
it's fine 48 no no no no by the rules so
I will move 72 dollars is that right
yeah 72 dollars
all right hang on I appreciate this man
who pays his debits I appreciate this a
priest I appreciate this because because
of the way they'll get mechanics work I
offer you well not that much hang on
called them 73 of those you have to give
me that makes one of those right am i
right is this fair fair's fair
you you you are you are a man of truth
you are a man of truth and I appreciate
right I appreciate that I appreciate
that
that is ballsy and I appreciate that not
everyone would do that not everyone who
do that all right what the hell you did
roll it at nine like I don't get why you
should ok chad is telling me apparently
few roll doubles it supersedes any sort
of special dice nonsense right all right
don't have enough to sell to buy a house
it's ok can i yeah I can add my turn
that's what I can forward to do all
right I
okay I'm gonna go ahead and pay my dues
what master monopoly player was that not
the correct maneuver there wasted one
turns $38 to get out right now
whatever happens there's an upside down
monopoly guy in your - there we go
listen wait come on now listen property
manager Bob I think that I'm Doody -
wait - give him good sound advice but
that doesn't mean we can't be friends
don't talk to me about fiducia s-- I
don't want to hear anything but like
you're gonna make my property value go
down if you've got property right next
to mine well that's kind of how property
works it was nice when it was just open
land and people had a nice scenic view
over there no to the railroad or not oh
my god [ __ ] damn it doesn't make any
sense so Bob we need to train I don't
have anything man I'm all dried up what
do you what do you need what do you want
dollar from you
okay how do I know I hold this down I
just hold right on the okay I feel like
you ever paid for your stay because
there's no longer a good scenic view
there so I just wanna give you some cash
Wow there you go buddy oh wow this is
this is nonsense what's happening this
is ridiculousness
this seems fair I did enjoy staying yeah
yeah no I think that's fair Mark's
properties really brought the value of
that stay down you know how does my
fault really mark what did I earn what
did I do and what did i do exactly those
big-ass houses over there oh my huge
houses I'm sorry about that
yeah no it's fine it's why they're nice
they just brought the value of mine down
so great and I just needed to square up
fair's fair you know fair's fair right
that I guess it's fair that's a markup
Liars promise I do have that tattooed on
my body it's true oh look at that roll
that's a nice roll let's do this all
right thank God I got those $200 oh I
own this property the same Baba might be
interested in that property yeah would
you want that but you don't have
anything that Bob oh no you do have
something that Bob wants you do have
some Bob likes I know what Bob wants I
know and look at me look at this boy
look how I'm gonna be right now I'm
gonna make it worth your day left look
at that look how even that trade is you
know am i right fair tasty fair's fair
I'm not saying I'd [ __ ] it but I'm not
saying I wouldn't what is fair what a
deal
dealin left and right what a deal you're
a deal maker that's what you are baby
I'm a mover and a shaker you are that
you're those a deal maker you are your
turn buddy Thanks you're just gonna
leave it there but uh someone to think
about how about mark here's a trade you
give me the orange you get to keep that
railroad and then you'll trade Bob the
railroad Bob will give me the orange or
no no I'll give Bob the orange how about
we both give Bob our oranges and
railroads what huh
you give Bob the orange in the railroad
I get Bob the orange and we call it fair
no no I was just trying to think of the
railroads that was a forward-thinking
deal Wade and I have not won your
creativity wow I thought I was a decent
deal but you know it's whatever hey if
you want that orange I think you just
got some Bob wants oh so if I trade you
the green mark
you'd give me the orange and then you'll
give Bob the green and the railroad and
then what I then I give you the orange
afterwards you know I think that you're
just trying to calm please
no wait I was following you I think you
had a right I think I think mark is just
confused that should have been a double
yeah I really need to lower the ring I
guess I should just go bankrupt what is
this how I do dollars off 470 not 1100
how do I do the thing I want to do I
want to do stuff to this thing control
who I mortgage you control Oh is out
that is yeah okay yes haha that's enough
okay well it's not for sale but you put
a for sale sign on there I guess that's
fine a little shady that's how
foreclosures happen randomly yes I go
fair fair square squares fair yeah fair
yeah okay all right let's do this
yes wherever don't know where that's
gonna send me but off I okay baby
yes you wanna pity give that to me what
have you got that you want to give to me
um I could pop my lip a little bit lay
down and some dirt and rip my clothes a
little bit what's your what's your
fantasy my fantasy you say well if I
didn't know I have so let me see what
you got I got to see I got to see what
you got orange wait wait let's see what
you got all right so you you want this
right you want this yo I'm just throwing
this out there I got a green and an
orange if you guys want to toss those in
the mix so you want this right you want
this I mean that's the thing so I got to
take something from you that you love
and shake Oh take something from you
that you want that is aggressive I would
take something from you that you love at
least even like the orange or something
no no no no no it's got to hurt
that's what I want that's what I want I
would counter Bob take that orange from
him I want it to hurt
mmm I'm thinking I'm thinking I'm
thinking look look there's only one
problem with this it's still gonna hurt
but what I need is some capital so I
don't die of starvation the next week or
two I want to buy a house that's all you
want no I'm gonna take the less than the
amount that I still wouldn't have enough
to buy a house it's 200 each this is
gonna put me under 200 I just need to
buy bread for my starving family okay
that's fair fair's fair
all right all right yeah you're right
all right fair's fair
fair's fair apparently that was a good
phrase yet no no no don't worry about it
no there's no way I think it's gonna
happen no no no no no no it's it's all
good I'm gonna put some houses on my
railroad put some house red the tracks
it's gonna be great everyone's gonna
love it all right let's roll some dice
where do you go move to five or seven
seven pick seven I can't
I feel like you should not mix up I
can't tell where five is chance yeah you
know let's take a chance go to boardwalk
did pay a thousand times that's pretty
good that's pretty good that's pretty
good hold on oh okay yeah so do anything
weird up up mm-hmm he's moving okay okay
that's good hang out wait to beat
himself first he's just not talking on
purpose I pressed the wrong button
nothing to say about this so I mean I
don't know I guess I'll take this for
that well I feel like oh no Bob
you just been so nice to me this game no
hang on the whole ball ball strategy of
me give him that the boardwalk was just
shooting it down in the first place was
just saying the hopes it he was gonna go
bankrupt shoot hang out wait
well he still will this family man many
concerns about this don't like it so if
you could pay off this mortgage wants to
stay here gets to stay here alright I
got one more trade to make with mark
here but I don't want to trade with you
don't listen to them no I don't think
that's a good thing yeah okay alright
I'm listening right and I need you to
help me pay back some of that money okay
for Bob so I will offer you that look
mark you you wondering why all these
good things are coming my way
I was generous to it's because I was
generous to wade okay all right let me
so if I take this deal what your only
good things will come for you if you
accept this out I'm saying this mark if
I get another proper teacher it's yours
okay so I get $1 yes and a lifetime
supply of officially sponsored wave luck
all right but you promised this is gonna
bring me luck no way how this doesn't
bring you your wildest dreams okay
all right my turn was gonna be bypassed
if I didn't do anything so but you
promised Bob that this is gonna be the
law so you
see you swear well I'm not even buying
this is a round of no buying this is
just enjoying alright this this nothing
bad will befall view my good sir I
absolutely guarantee it
there you are apparently apparently I
got the other brown one hey hey look and
guess who is in line to get that bad boy
guess who you got to guess I don't know
that's right
who gets the brown one the luckiest man
of all coming to your inbox at this
exact moment holy [ __ ] look at that
discount value you can't beat that folks
you don't see anything like this in
stores it's TV only today only you're
saying that if I take this deal
undoubtedly it's gonna go good for me
round will happen will be whatever you
imagine your future to be will come to
pass imagine me waiting for a full set i
imagine me winning okay all right okay
all right okay but you promised abso
likely likely absolutely likely it's
pretty good likely sounds nice you know
yeah okay I also I also forgot unlikely
that the last few turns have taken so
long I forgot what was happening that
good roll my friend good roll thank you
thank you thank you you know I just
wanted to stop on my own property felt
good to be here that's pretty cool you
know what I know what I'm gonna do I
know what I'm gonna do
watch this uh boom ah [ __ ] boom
Oh boom
there we go man spending it up like a
true I am yeah I am alright I think
that's good for me okay you you were
right Bob
you you you right you were right I feel
pretty lucky unfathomable success is
coming your way my friend yes yes look
at that
this was a really nice stay you know
this was a really nice day mark but I'm
gonna have to trade with you here wait
what what what we just talked about the
stay I had it was so good I'm gonna pay
extra Wow
oh I feel like Lux just on your side
right now I just feel like I owe you
more haha okay no call it call it some
kind of crazy luck tuition or something
like there you go double the rent
alright I don't know just I feel like
there's just something I just need to
pay you more yeah okay alright race car
let's go fast shall we just go right to
jail lots of fat just oh that's not good
wait it's monopoly guy whatever that I'm
here mark has overlooked mark is bought
himself what other percent of luck
raining on the board yeah I didn't
believe you
I didn't believe you when you said I had
all the luck and now I got why would you
not believe this no no I don't know why
oh look at you dodging tasty spicy
[Music]
material over here it feels good guys
feels good feels good
fine known man you guys really knew the
secret trying to tell you man you did
you did you tried to tell me I didn't
listen good
there we go Oh times turning green it's
on the up some raced racing around
jamming around marks just bopping it I
know a little bit but I think I just
want to like I want my oranges to be a
little bit nicer for you hey wait listen
just one just one it's fine that's not
so good at all please make the roll that
makes me go into jail okay well that's
what I don't know that's about happening
right now I don't know well I get to
select what is that what's happening
right now is I'm getting to select where
I go I guess yeah cuz I rolled triples
go to jail no I'm gonna look I've got
strats I've got some thought oh I see
what you're doing that makes sense yeah
yeah I get to go where I please
I own the sprout up joyful good job
waterworks that watched everything right
now
hi well with that much fire that I also
caught fire and died of burns all right
ooh baby
yeah I love not knowing where I'm going
I'm here feels lucky this doesn't feel
no no it could have been way worse I've
had houses burn my extra cash flow I
threw your way I didn't burn anything I
believe this is a family stream don't
spurn things I didn't spurn nothing no
do it but I am about to spurn oh I don't
need to go again
you know you know I am baby but I
probably shouldn't do this before I get
through this Avenue but here I go I am
responsible man that's smart Bob and I
are basically already there my Luck's on
my side I got I still got big rolls big
doubles go directly to boardwalk it's
fun place nice nice mark do you smell
the luck mark is literally bursting out
of your feet like you wait at TGI
Fridays that's some big roll all right
mystery I was too big for my services
Wow guys everyone listen to Bob when he
tells you that something is gonna be all
luck all day he is not lying not I can't
who knows what that is
wait hang on game listen let's talk
about this where's that Oh all day every
luck every way Donna roll again now good
who's gonna feel lucky you can choose
you can choose choose a one just go to
boardwalk or for you get forest
Community Chest yeah yeah
four is a good one let's do four whole
come on oh yeah that's alright that's
okay it's alright crazy I'm about to
make raise the LACMA I'm about to make
them right on you okay cool great okay
Bob enjoy the scenic views of my houses
that's what it's time for if I just
don't roll do I not get to go boys
that's good I'll just I like Community
Chest you see that blue building you see
how it is that you see the good chest
there's nothing better than laying on a
good chest you know yeah you you you
look look before I do anything I think
we all know what needs to happen yeah
definitely a smart move definitely
before you roll I agree mmm all right
hang on hang on hang on Han oh my god if
I hit end I can just go bankrupt right
now that's not what I want
she's like the game's way of saying like
don't do this I've been away for too
long I perturb we bypass 2:24 so no I
have to think about this okay yep 20
seconds
that's gotta be good that's my property
- we playing [ __ ] it was all my
hesitancy this through she knows what he
means good it's fine it's probably by
far the good suck you know me spots are
the bomb all right all right listen Wade
yeah you you don't have any money either
[Laughter]
can I do what can i what can i suck to
make this right can you just like I
don't even if I do that that gets me up
to 6:30 oh I got that got this I got to
see it I hate to see it no no no this is
what must be done I actually like to see
it so I'm okay with I love this must to
be done the face
[Music]
I will obey their command and I will be
happy about it mm-hmm okay all right
I accidentally placed that house and it
is like just keeps getting hit by him
not me so you've got a luck man
yeah I got the luck well that's not so
bad you'll bake 130 come in way worse
all right wait listen if you could roll
a 14 ah buddy that looks kind of like a
14 there's a 1 and a 4 that is close I
appreciate your lack of understanding of
numbers forgive you for it go to
boardwalk oh go to boardwalk and pay
triple please it's time to upgrade my I
just feel like you guys deserve a nicer
state it would ruin the property value
was on it was unparalleled it was the
most beautiful three houses I've ever
stayed at is oh that's excessive much
now you're just like you're really oh
boy all right okay yeah how much well
the minimum bid is a hundred oh no okay
I see I see well that's not good I'm
just gonna let you guys fight this one
out all right $10 for this house yeah
all right okay okay all yours buddy
oh thank you you're welcome damn it all
right oh man I've been looking forward
to this
like it's fine everything's fine
this button that will help is all you
need please fidget spitter of destiny
and now I wish I would have given you 30
bucks okay 31 for one I think that
sounds more than completely unreasonable
for some reason this is some kind of
[ __ ] I will take no more no less my
good sir deals done alright look at that
and pay you and everyone is fine feels
like some kind of [ __ ] bye okay
whatever I just try to keep my good
buddy Bob playing well it's fine I just
because you are having all of this
ungodly luck to me you gave me the lock
you gave me all of the luck so honestly
you should oh oh the one you didn't
mortgage okay fine yeah wait $26 go to
need some bread you said it's not gonna
be for free oh no that's so close to the
right thing you did it wrong though you
can pay for it hey listen yeah awesome
you there so you could select hey
honored $75 holy [ __ ] that sucks so it's
only one house man I chose to give you
money you could just no I appreciate
that I do appreciate that I just thought
it was gonna be more money that's that's
my bad really it's a really nice
beachfront property but okay
going just real I'm gonna fidget spinner
was not nice to me what can I do I'm
gonna use this screen cleaning spray I'm
gonna I'm gonna use the cap and just I
like it ha I like it
oh thank you thank you sweet merciful
monopolist hey how's it going wait how's
your stay it's great man
how's the Hatrack the parking here oh
man please give me triplets just kids
coming out there mark oh man we're all
even and totally on the same level in
this game yeah all right now listen mark
yes yes I know you have so much luck if
you could turn some of that down for me
all right I know it's asking you to do
it's it's wrong do me like that you know
I like doing things that I like doing
cruel I chose the lane odd Bob and you
chose the bypass him yeah I did no no
that's not what I want I want this I
have the last house I paid an exorbitant
amount of money for why would I do that
why would I do this it's worth everyone
hits the brown you know what fine I get
it I get it it's fine it's fair is fair
actually wait I have an idea here okay I
have an idea no I'm not I'm not gone and
wait I have an idea see I'm gonna do a
maneuver I gotta be careful with this
last one here I got I remember I gotta
be careful about the Occident
great oh yeah oh yeah
fair is fair fair is fair and now there
are some houses up on the market oh yeah
so fair's fair
it's no fair it hurts fair is fair you
guys like those Brown places okay Ike it
is they're gonna see the board you know
where I'm gonna be later pay luxury tax
you land on my hotel or you pay income
tax that's your choice right now I think
you definitely want that's not the one I
was gonna say you gonna buy houses
that's what you're going to do black
couple really want one there come back
somewhere deep in the recesses of my
mind I think I'm I'm assembling a vision
of how the my path forward through the
darkness it really is the valley of the
shadow of death around them but I know
[Laughter]
my
the red dice is really yeah all right
here we go I told you what I had seen
all right nice Jail visit buddy
that why you gotta say it like that I
mean you just said it real weird what
nice Jail visit buddy yeah the way
you're like that it just feels a little
threatening and a little attacking it I
don't know nothing wrong with a little
jail buddy how's that weird okay you you
right you right
we need some mom we need some big big
dick energy here is this another goddamn
rail no winning this I am gonna be very
upset if you measure by who is currently
winning if you measure success in the
way that I measure success Road that
might be a railroad oh it is you know
dude always takes you to a railroad a
nice well you went to an electric
company I guess that's true I guess it's
the closest bad property or something I
think this is a probe closest like none
it's either unknown no it's always
unknown so it always goes to a not owned
property but if everything's owned it
would go tour or not a property that I
don't know what we're not yours yeah
exactly
this is gonna take me back now oh hi
hello
why here it's cheap man that's a cheap
ring I got a five whatever it's fine hey
Bob where'd you go
I'm here okay hello everything's good I
was making fun of you but you couldn't
hear me so you hit my house why did you
hit my house you hit my house fun of me
really nice whoo New York Avenue those
look kind of like slums some not gonna
lie like crack houses
yes buy more that'll help yeah that look
like crack houses more the jury I got
some nice hotels if you wanna take a
take a load off I need to remind myself
of the path forward his search deep
December a little bit of whoo into the a
odds and with myself into their
protection oh dear no can I just stay on
go listen that doesn't look too good
wasn't there I would be happy with the
amount that I paid okay you know I need
you to come visit me I don't want to I
don't want to that's a high number okay
back for your shitty motel what's wrong
with my motel it's garbage okay well
some people need less expensive hotel
not all hotels can be four-star some
people need to get a place to sleep for
on the cheap you know what I mean like
twos twos are good
Bobby super stressed no hey don't be
like that it's not funny no I mean is my
properties and forget my troubles for a
minute houses are there left do I think
more than one at least one well I'm
gonna buy something impulsively to feel
better that's not good that's money than
you listen mark yes do you want all my
greens for like for like $300 and then
I'll pay you the $200 out of that you
know what you know what huh
keep your greens I want to leave you
with just one dollar cuz the railroads
there were yours in the beginning so I
owe you 200 and I have a six so you want
to give me I will give you one hundred
and fifteen eighteen thirteen no I need
to give you one hundred and fifteen you
need to give me 100 one hundred and
sixteen actually and then you won and
that'll leave you with one dollar one
hundred and sixteen and then you won I
don't know if that's right but all is
right look it's right I think it's right
I didn't do the yeah do that
huh alright alright I like it I like it
yeah cuz you you own the railroads you
were the previous owner and that
industry in this world I want you to be
able to afford a loaf of bread I've
always wanted to leave you with this
little bread I've hanging on to my
dollar and my dignity
I appreciate you sir welcome Bob all
right I think this is really gonna work
out for me I think it will do here we go
Oh unfortunate for me not busting Lee
close all right
listen like a nice double eight you'll
land on a green that's mortgage no
problem how are you doing this no some
of those houses back I'm gonna use the
money you're gonna get me towards my
next house on my path to ultimate
victory the path do you see the path I
walk the path son oh [ __ ] sold purple oh
you know what no I want I want purple
like purple
I like oh there you go buddies look at
that blue creams I in last place
one loaves of bread
you know seven is the loneliest number
they believe in seven Bob believe in
seven I can do this you've got a little
five oh you guys I'm gonna roll a ten
then I'm gonna roll a ten then I'm gonna
rot in jail okay that's very narrow but
I have skinny feet and I wanted know
[Laughter]
[Music]
what happened to you it's big baby
I don't know if that's what you want
that's exactly what you wanted to do
what is wave get to go to jail my turns
over oh just paid my hundred dollars now
oh yeah oh yeah wait this is that's the
least person that deserves to go to jail
that's not okay okay I'm homeless
shouldn't I already be in jail I have
three dollars did almost as many
properties let's do this I can't boss I
got the blush nice what do I get no one
would be good to use a chest six is
Community Chest all right vault
Community Chest you've been bad to me in
the past you owe me it'll be good this
time Scott homie I practically winning
this [ __ ] the path is narrow but it is
true oh yeah Wade you do use it jail
free card right you should come run
around man
just travel the world to see some stuff
it's pay me some money please all right
I rolled that's okay
yeah luck is on my side good roll I mean
I was gonna buy another house but they
won't sell it to me for $7.00 mark yes
and 19 okay all right hey guys would
please okay all right that's probably
not the right guy you yeah it's fine
will you pay it for him why would I do
that cause you like the kindness of your
heart he fairly gave him $2 giving you I
was begging you outside of the luxury
hotel at which you were residing for the
evening
this is humanitarian
from your taxes oh you're right taxes
are roll unless you give me your word I
give you some words oh that's more words
than I've ever had before
oh that's monopoly guy what are you
doing here no listen I didn't invite you
only four ways properties you already
have the railroads yes so what if I give
you the oh you can have man I don't have
a lot to offer oh that one that's a good
one yeah that's a good one and it's
worth more right than what you owe so if
you just gave me how much joy needs to
pay you off it's a hundred hundred and
ten so I I'll just I'll take oh I will
leave myself with $1 my good sir fair's
fair
I'll pay the full market value I don't
want market value fitty I don't want it
written down in the transfer that it was
sold below value for tax reasons I want
I want to pay the full that does tend to
get you audited yes so I would rather
fair is fair well ahead of Wade you
don't yeah you did somehow survive
another lap around
yeah I don't understand how but can you
please find a way to roll it to no good
roll good roll please please please
[Laughter]
alright I'm getting close to $100 again
man how's it mark after roll are you
gonna make me going in game this seems
unfair I feel like I'm being targeted
okay there's nothing to do now except
follow the path that is set before me
you know the path which is one of great
poverty and suffering oh thank god I
think I'm I think I'm good for me I
think mine is that yours it's a nine so
all I have to do is not a seven or a
nine
oh sorry eight or six one eight or six
eight or a cigarette
wait you've been good to me I will offer
you the same offer that mark gave to me
I will leave you with one dollar my poor
friend
a dollar so you give me one dollar and I
give you how much did you need 28 so you
need to give me 80 so I needed $22 so
I'll take 23 for yeah yeah yeah more
than fair
oh dude that's very generous gets his
money back as much money as I was hoping
but that deal that deal did not screw
you completely okay but you could have
made himself some houses so may this
journey a little less treacherous no not
really
I don't know you can see on the board
map if you go board map you'll see I can
tell you Bob that mark and I probably
won't be able to outbid you
[Laughter]
right bidding you for that one house
alright so this one becomes 500 with two
ounces on this one becomes 1,400 with
three houses even 'm okay well then I
know what I must do
the path is clear is clear
I'm gonna bid at least I'm gonna let you
guys have some fun let's do that well I
can't that's too high for my boy well I
couldn't make a less than than one so
I'm sorry I remember when I had money
once upon a time some money I had money
I had okay just declare bankruptcy
because it seems like a similar scenario
to the tebab getting Redemption for the
last episode somehow we've come
full-circle out like it nothing can go
wrong
the path is set and I am obeying what I
have been told is that good alright it's
not terrible I think you're on the last
door oh that could be that could be
worse it could be worse could be worse
could be worse could be worse you know
that's not bad I'll take that yes we're
getting fresh bread
I can't [ __ ] believe I've not out of
this close to being out so long welcome
welcome this this house is really not
that great it's I've been in better it
wasn't really worth it
where where shall I go now where will I
go I don't roll of course that makes
sense
wait no that is what I rolled right
isn't that actually when I rolled you're
welcome but this house really sucked
worse than the luxury are happy to
welcome to you to to one of my many
comfortable estate wow what a roll go to
boardwalk go directly to bedrock don't
don't do anything else but go to this
you really ought about this all
boardwalk thing I think you got great
okay it's a nice place to stay I feel
like it's underrated what about Park
Place Park place pretty play you want to
role Oh - we all roll blow down here in
a roll go big go big or hello
well oh go big man I'm gonna lowball
estimates I'm gonna roll this one with
air pods okay that's the kind of person
I am now please keep me wealthy okay
I'm not somewhere who knows who knows
what there it's okay all right wait
needs all the money he can get he's like
us all even on come on
it's time for a luxury vacation oh oh
oh I think you skipped it no no you
didn't hey you want $1 for $200 I don't
even have that many dollars oh I do have
a rich again okay for me one that's good
good good good getting closer yeah good
good good look you're gonna have money
left over you suck so much because he's
just gonna buy more houses I couldn't
possibly
listen hey you know what painted full
paid in full what amen what a true
gentleman didn't have to go everything's
fine everyone needs to just calm down I
enjoyed my free stamp that was a very
nice at least you have money in so many
houses to pull from I don't I don't I've
got [ __ ] houses oh yeah I was so glad
you chose to invest in those instead of
your yellows but you know oh please oh
how much is it oh really that's what you
get that's what you get for being
confident that's what gives my pot that
is my punishment what you get well I
don't have a whole lot of choice I guess
through that I'm still wealthy yeah me
mark you get your money last place to
anyone all right here we go
I big big moves mark roll here we go
here we go here we go here we go here we
go here we go here we go here we go here
we go
what's the one that makes my think you
should move one right here one sounds
good three is really nice I like I guess
force free parking and that's pretty
good one but if you get one you might
get to take a sweet vacation too boy
don't lie to me just Community Chest
have a possibility to go into a railroad
chance
I don't know anybody you win money or
you lose money yeah I don't think you I
think chances where you go places isn't
it I don't know I'm not know that for
sure honestly but were you holding back
on me Community Chest can go to
boardwalk I don't know I don't know I
was just hoping everyone should go to
boardwalk listen wait somehow do it to
me nine bucks no way in hell I don't
even have nine bucks this is a personal
problem you've got nine bucks yeah not
to spare I'm about to have to spend them
on some douche bag shitty motel no no
it's not a motel it's a hotel it might
be a motel it does say motel you are
correct about that I don't even know
thanks hope you enjoyed the bedbugs
oh look at that that's a good room yes a
good one is what you wanted Wow
best property that I got that's pretty
good man that's pretty so but you're so
close to a hundred you're so close to
that continues to improve as you go far
no one's landed on red thirty let's go
just know we're minuscule roles car
we've seen the path I whisper to you
between the brakes here we feel me okay
hey that's fine please don't be a
railroad I beg of you okay buddy
hold me my main man Rolo okay you got it
buddy
yes oh you own this property look at you
alright yeah it's good you guys are
going real fast can we slow this down I
don't want to roll again and I want to
be put in that position those are high
numbers how do I see to your area 11
would be over into your ear there that
would be free parking 11 yes your purple
your third purple that's good no I think
you want to hurry on around to the cool
side of July I saved this for special
occasions but it is time please yes
don't kill me don't do it good is that
good or bad I don't know that's could be
worse
I've been the same as going one more to
the left
and it would been a lot worse to be one
more to the right all right I've been
waiting as 30 I've been waiting for this
moment all my life I've been waiting for
this oh wait oh no wait no I read five
yes you were on a double it's possible
anything's possible
oh all right
oh my god I like the chest I like the
chest
I like the chest I like do I that's okay
it's okay it's okay
because I'm about to execute my greatest
maneuver how many has a lady god dammit
why are there only two I'm about to
execute my greatest maneuver okay order
66 yeah oh it's order 66 all right wait
wait I have an I have the crazy I have
the craziest idea I don't know if this
is gonna work I would wait no I have the
craziest idea okay wait oh I'm bidding
on this [ __ ] right okay oh I am did I
win no all right I'm out I'm in here
wait you you good
I already withdrew I can't do anything
now all right cool nice house purchase
man thanks man all right now I will do
this by that and I don't know if this is
gonna work
are you gonna sell all your houses and
try to rebuy them
that is so cheap for the record she is
cheap Bob you're muted this is the most
exploitive [ __ ] wow that sucks
just withdrawal with work will never bid
and it will never end I won't do it more
than this one and it would feel real
[ __ ] it doesn't feel just I wanted I
just wanted to see if it would work and
that was more than if I feel bad for
that cuz that's obviously exploitative
so I won't do any more oh my god that
it's in the game man it's in the game
that would be the most brutal way cuz I
would I would just transfer all my house
opponents oh my god so you roll into
your own area yeah I believe in my area
what voice I've used all my tricks
I have no they left going to be the role
that ends the dream hey Purple's are
mortgaged if you get past the light
blues the Purple's are safe the vision
is real of course you landed on him and
not me
listen no wait I have more moves mark
uh-huh I got a you want a complete set I
do I've been playing a lot of Tetris
lately I do like completing things
complete set here and I'm paying you
this money right back to you there's
very fair is fair can I offer you some
chick-fil-a for some money I would take
some chick-fil-a right now but no all
right mark listen buddy I really need
this to happen okay what happened to all
the games money how do we not know but
that's mine
please do it for me and makes you feel
any better red has been abandoned by thy
God all right okay that's basically my
one shot is my chance here comes my one
shot I'm going through boardwalk Avenue
mom's spaghetti you're not even there oh
no it's gonna be the stupid railroad
Marc doesn't need that okay it's mine
okay I have to go again the greens I'm
thinking I'm thinking yes I'm thinking
that one's already mortgaged this one
yes give me the give me the month's how
much I owe you Marc 3:30 3:30
okay listen yes this hurts me as much or
more than it hurts you
gotcha but I'm gonna pay my debt I'm
gonna pay what I owe a good job for a
charity 37 so Bob and I could at least
be taught
no no I'm beating you I'm winning number
here apparently yes all right all right
you won't
my turn
alright wait I didn't get to win last
time I gave you the game that's fair
it's only 450 win there you go you got
it bud okay please just get away from
marks [ __ ] don't land on a
[ __ ] weird monopoly guy if you
let if you do if you do me I think
you're fine don't monopoly my God did
not make sense he sent you to the next
property owned by someone who's not you
look Hey so mark listen yes you want you
want to be like you like things that are
green am i right look I it's so to give
him not all of them it's only later 15
on mortgage oh my no I'll take them I'll
give you two of them for how much look
okay I'll give you all three of them
I'll give them all of you plus you give
me $300 plus the amount I owe you so I
pay you 200 I get I end up gaining $300
for giving you all three greens so I
have to give you 500 and yes just 500
even just 500 even all right okay oh I
have to do that hang on
I think this is getting me back on the
path yeah - to victory this is the way
oh yeah oh absolutely it's meant to go
absolutely wait you're practically dead
already
all right okay all right we'll do it
like this everyone always lands on the
Reds so good so good I'm gonna go and
unmoor gauge these oh definitely
definitely want to do that and then to
hondo back there you go my Frank you was
not good for me somehow when you see
deals that aren't going I'm so good
suddenly affecting you in a negative way
okay I'm going all-in
no where's people that know you know in
this particular version with a little
man on the dice I feel like railroads
are actually a lot more powerful because
you're forced into them with the hand
you get a lot of railroads in this game
mode roads are total waste this version
I think they're actually really powerful
boom I want you can you please pick a no
I can't what is 10/10 would be I'm gonna
go for a chance tends boardwalk I would
hey wait look how much more money I have
than you
hey only slightly just you wait I'm
making some money this turn Oh make
those moves that's good well that's no
that's what you want
oh man that's railroad suck pretty good
right pretty good mark my three Purple's
four greens market value no salomon
mortgage cuz he wants to buy him because
he's a rich douchebag
oh I don't I'm trying to make it safer
for you Bob to make your way through
there we're safe
and now orange is safer now that there's
no people in it what are the people it's
not the place it's the people that are
the day I feel like you're not passing
on the good to me and I feel like that's
gonna come back to bite you in the butt
this will turn my Luckies been so good
this whole time I'm so about guys guys
just give me just a nice five no no mr.
monopoly [ __ ] oh just I'm gonna figure
out where he lives and I'm gonna go and
kill his dogs bring his dogs back and be
like this is what you did you did this
so don't come don't come near me
monopoly man did get some five in this
motel I understand but the manager my
wife I want my money back well I'm so
glad I've rented that house you know
it's like you know you could read
unaffordable on the on the hilltop look
at that [ __ ] you see that [ __ ] that's
some nice [ __ ] it's like I'm like rice
gum paying 50 grand a month for my house
it's worth it for the experience of it I
know cuz my money is always gonna be
rolling in my money is always gonna be
cranking in hey look listen I'm just
barely back on some Pink's or oranges
off of me Pink's for uh for Honda
they're mortgaged that's as they are
they are no no how rich you think I am
eleven hundred rich you happen I got
plans for that already
Bob you need more properties if you're
gonna come back and win look at this
mortgages any dollar seventy so 140 so
222 unmoor gauge how much do you want
just four hundred you know three hundred
for the pain you know what here three
three fiddy three-fitty why are you
going down from here even he didn't even
say no trying to rope he's trying to
rope me in right okay I don't want to
screw Bob but also I want to be bailed
out you know you could have sold your
houses
you could've just sold your houses you
could shut the [ __ ] up over there I want
you to keep those houses cuz that shows
a little chaos let's do that let's get
that let's get these bad boys up and
running I feel like I feel like I feel
like this is unfair why you just got a
lot of money
look it's like a competition is good for
everyone mark yeah this competition
keeps the capitalist this game was named
competition but that's not what the name
of this game is it's good for everyone
where's everybody right now I'm about to
go hit he'll run
I don't think marks gonna hit boardwalk
after Park Place I don't know if I'm
that lucky highly doubt it
where you at cuz you might need to look
somewhere you're at
no no look you guys spend money to make
money I am I remember these were decent
places man I remember that yeah I got
houses on the ones please get on please
go to my properties please go to my
properties monopoly man I will kill your
dogs oh I like young Brooks comment uh
feel like this is unfair says the man
who was winning and uses an exploit to
make more money alright here we go
let's do it no give me those fifty
buckos you can have it you know cuz
Illinois's coming up next because how
wait how much one house one wait sell
your goddamn houses nope
why not you're gonna you gonna no you're
gonna just end your [ __ ] get out of here
Oh your tune has changed from the UH fun
Bob Oh fun friendly Bob coop oh wait
what have you done
oh no wave no what have you done won hey
why are you Bob worried feel bad about
this what's win like this it's fine it's
happened for Mark well I think you
alright
no you have a bunch of houses wait damn
houses do I get do I keep the houses if
you if you just declares bankruptcy
though I think yeah
Wow holy [ __ ] mark I know how you felt
now which feels good prepared my wrongs
we never have to play this game again I
shall leave those [ __ ] mortgaged I
don't even care permission to rage quit
if you want mark no it's okay I feel
like I want to play this one out I just
feel you know I see a path Bob give me
one give me my turn I feel I see the
path it's just it's guiding you to roll
a nice sweet thirteen oh yeah let's just
see where it goes and Illinois the path
is ahead of me thank you
and that's not so bad
I declare bankruptcy at any time I got I
got Ubisoft Club action the master Wow
so you understand why I was so upset
about right I'm not upset that Wayde
declared bankruptcy I'm fine with that I
was up I even you
even you were like oh yeah you're
probably gonna we're down to like $1 and
boardwalk and Park Place and that's in
you I'm perfectly happy and no floods
landed on my god damn rent oh yeah no I
am shocked because there's even a chance
card that let goes to red light I have
no idea sure
[Laughter]
[Music]